sinon tu es venu nous parler de quoi bah
a priori Noël les courses voilà
l'inflation le bon plan non la
difficulté quand même pour une part des
Français parce que malgré tout faire
Noël sousension c'est quand même pas
c'est une tané c'est une tan alors
l'inflation a impacté Noël quand même
oui parce que ben c'est on est tous sous
la contrainte financière et pour vous
donner un chiffre parce que vous savez
que j'aime les choses factuelles
l'alimentation elle a progressé de 25 %
en 2 ans les salaires si je prends le
SMIC par exemple sur la même période a
fait 10 % ça çaut dire que on a tous
perdu du pouvoir d'achat alimentaire on
n pas perdu de pouvoir d'achat global à
quelque chose près parce que l'inflation
générale a été du même niveau que
l'inflation des salaires mais pour les
familles modestes la part de
l'alimentation oui en proportion c'est
beaucoup plus élevé donc c'est la double
peine donc ça veut dire qu'au moment de
mettre du foie gras ou du champagne ou
du saumon B ça pique beaucoup plus pour
ceux qui n'ont pas beaucoup d'argent
parce qu'en proportion de leur budget
c'est énorme mais c'est ça c'est c'est
un truc de fou c'est il y a eu vraiment
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui j'ai plein de
gens qui me disent c'est vrai que là
cette année Noël ça va être aussi très
compliqué pour les cadeaux oui et c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs que pour le moment ce
que l'on voit par exemple c'est que le
jouet se porte pas très bien que les
cadeaux se portent moins bien parce que
il va falloir arbitrer entre ce qu'on
met au pied du sapin et ce qu'on met
dans l'assiette et au final parce qu'on
est des Latins on est des Français on
aime bouffer disons-le assez simplement
bah on va préserver ce qu'on met dans
l'assiette au risque d'enlever un cadeau
au pied du sapin voilà c'est ça ça c'est
ça alors beaucoup revendent aussi leurs
cadeaux de noël c'est ce qui su pris oui
parce que désormais on peut le faire
super facilement on a tous des
applications type bon coin et autres
c'est pas la seule mais où en gros ben
on peut soit parce qu'on aime pas soit
parce qu'on se dit ça a de la valeur et
je pourrais récupérer pour en faire
autre chose donc oui un business de la
revente de cadeau de Noël et qui
commence dès le 24 au soir dès le 25 au
matin on voit les offres arrivver sur
sur tous les sites c'est assez fascinant
ouais ouais alors il faut pas voilà il
faut pas se faire choper par celui qui
vous a offert le cadeau si vous revendez
tous un robot de merde ça va se vous je
dis parce pas eu donc c'est pour ça
Olivier je t'offre un robot ah c'est
gentil
pas d'ailleurs je
présente profite de la présence
d'Olivier et de son blouson pour
rappeler que il faut utiliser le sac à
sapin il en faut tellement plus pourer
ça j' mais c'est important de le dire
voilà c'est important deà l'utile à
l'agréable comment un repas de Noël sans
se ruiner bon euh il faut déjà prendre
qu' pas culà de départ on achète que des
produits en promo il y a dans toutes les
enseignes entre 200 300 400 produits
quand vous additionnez le champagne le
foie gras le saumon la volaille il y a
de la promo partout donc de grâce vous
n'achetez pas autre chose que ce qui est
dans le prospectus moi j'encourage les
voilà de manière très très bête vous
prenez les prospectus que vous avez reçu
dans votre boîte au lettrre si vous
n'avez pas ça parce que vous avez mis
stop pub il y a des applications à
chaque fois je vous je vous en parle
parce que elle est bien ça s'appelle
Bonal il y en a d'autres aussi vous avez
tous les bons plats autour de chez vous
vous n'achetez que des produits qui sont
soit sur ces applications soit sur le
prospectus est sur les promos parce que
parfois vous nous disiez qu'il y avait
des promos qui étaient des des faux amis
oui mais de toute façon celle qui n'est
pas oui c'estàd c'est pas des vraies
bonnes promos parce que le prix on l'a
augmenté avant bon mais dans mais dans
les fait malgré tout ne prenez quand
même que ça parce que de toute façon le
reste ça sera forcément encore moins
intéressant par exemple n'achetez pas du
foie gras qui n'est pas à 34 % de
réduction c'est super facile vous en
avez part pourquoi 34 parce que la lo ne
permet pas de faire des réduction de
plus de 34% c'est pour ça que je
donneance oui bien sûr ou plus sur les
produits alimentaires on ne peut pas
faire plus de 34 % de remise ou 68 % sur
le deè produit comme vous savez compter
ça fait 34 voilà donc on n'a pas le
droit de faire ça 34 68 voilà c'est
l'équivalent du 2+ 1 de produits achetés
un produit offert et ça c'est la loi qui
l'oblige mais voilà le foie gras c'est
34 % après si vous voulez radiner un peu
ben vous n'achetez pas pas un chapon
vous achetez un poulet fermier c'est
alors ça sera moins bon mais si vous
voulez par exemple l'améliorer vous lui
fourrez avec un Boursin que vous lui
mettez dans le croupion vous allez voir
il va être super ouais mais bien
sûr mais oui une fois mort évidemment
parce que sinon ça pourrait lui plaire
voy le chapon qu'on met souvent est un
produit cher en chapon ça vaut
aujourd'hui entre 12 et 14 € le kilo
pour vous donner un ordre de prix le
chapon et c'est et c'est une grosse
pièce ouais le poulet castré et c'est
une grosse pièce asuce si vous voulez
faire des économies ben vous avez des
poulets fermiers qui valent à peu près
la moitié du prix alors c'est moins gras
c'est moins onctueux c'est moins goûttu
mais vous compensez voilà par exemple
c'est une bonne ID c'est une super idée
en V bien ça le Boursin
ouaisère tu vas voir oua avec avec
quelques croûons dedans vous allez voir
mais voilà vous vous améliorez les
choses fais ça toi tu fais ça tu vas
mettre de Boursin dans le je l'essayer
la semaine dernière pour voir si je le
recommencerai pas pour Noël ben c'était
fort bon ah ouais c'est vrai ouais
franchement franchement ououais je vais
pas le faire cette année
mais merde pas tiens Gill Verdez celui
qu'on surnomme le chapon dans le métier
j'ai été très surpris parce que je suis
allé dans un supermarché ce matin
effectivement il y a déjà énormément de
promotions donc ma question je me suis
dit dans ma tête est-ce que c'est parce
que les gens achètent moins que les
supermarchés font les promotions avant
Noël alors en réalité ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que ce sont les marques qui
font des promotions et les supermarché
qui vous les répercut c'est-à-dire que
c'est laabry sur le saumon c'est
delperra sur le foig gras c'est les
grandes marques de champagne avec
modération qui le font ainsi c'est elles
parce qu'elles ont bien compris que si
elles ne font pas de promotion elles
n'auront pas de consommateur je parce
que on est quand même face à une
descente en gamme de ce qu'on met dans
nos assiettes par exemple pour vous
donner un chiffre sur le dernier mois
les ventes de champagne on fait - 20 %
en France les ventes de mousseux ont
fait zéro et donc ce qu'il faut regarder
c'est l'écart entre les deux je peux
vous prendre un autre exemple le saumon
fumé a fait - 100 Ah ouais la truite
fumée qui coûte moins cher alors elle a
une vertu elle est française hein
souvent la truiteou c'est pas plus mal
elle a fait plus 5 en fait on a un écart
entre des produits Premium et des
produits un peu moins Premium qui
traduisent ce que l'on fait dans notre
comportement c'estàdire on descend en
gamme le saumon de toutes les marques la
berie le saumon oui aujourd'hui il est
en baisseere marque delperra la derie
toutes les marques de distribut c'est
celle de schuberk oui c'est ça ou non
mais la truite très sérieusement en plus
environnement environnementalement
parlant ça vient des Pyrénées soit du
côté français soit du côté espagnol dans
tous les cas c'est plus près que la
Norvège ou que l'Écosse vous remarquer
j'ai fait je viens de faire une blague
pour nos amis
méloman merci à eux voilà de la kiffer
est-ce que les promotions sont des
vraies promotions c'est qu'est-ce qu'il
grugent pas sur les prix pour baisser ou
est-ce qu'il mett pasité alle si il y a
toujours ce risque là bien évidemment
mais ce qui est certain c'est que si
vous ne prenez pas ceux qui sont pas en
promo déjà sur le prospectus ben
forcément vous allez les payer plus cher
donc ce risque il existe par principe
mais raison de plus pour nous regarder
encore plus que ça venre poser la même
question il a
minutes je te j tu fais une très
mauvaise émission tu fais une très
maaise émion je te le dis arrête quand
ton stag vient tu fais une très mauvaise
émission je te le dis je te le dis ou
j'ai cru comprendre qu'il y avait une
surproduction de fois gras cette année
pour compenser celle de l' dernière et
que donc il y aurait des promotions plus
importantes tu as remarqué lui à chaque
fois qu'il pose une question il est
vraiment dans une enquête deou j'ai cru
comprendre qu'il y avait une production
de c'est c'est en partie vrai en partie
faux on en a non non mais vous allez
voir il y en a un peu plus que l'année
dernière mais il y en a moins que ce à
quoi on était habitué avant parce que on
sort de la grippe aviare on a vidé
beaucoup d'élevages parce qu'il a fallu
abattre des milliers des milliers de
canards on les a fait rerentrer on les a
vacciné donc déjà ça a impacté le prix
du foie gras parce que il faut payer le
vaccin parce que forcément ça se
répercute et malgré tout on n pas encore
reconstitué la totalité du chaptel
français donc on manque un peu de foie
gras et le foie gras cette année coûte
très exactement 9 % de plus en moyenne
que l'année dernière donc c'était déjà
un produit cher c'est pas en train de
diminuer et si on attend le dernier
moment il y aura des bonnes promos alors
le truc qu'il faudrait faire dans
l'absolu c'est attendre le 25 décembre
parce que vous avez effectivement faire
Noël le 26 exactement là vous faites de
sacré économies vous n'êtes pas allez
obséd par les convenan non c'est relou
de faire Noël le 26
arrê compris pour les cadeaux pour
acheter vous pouvez aussi vous dire
quand vous êtes modeste vous ne décidez
pas à l'avance du menu que vous allez
faire vous le décidez le 24 après-midi
dans l'absolu quand vous allez faire vos
courses vous allez forcément trouver des
produits que le magasin doit écouler je
vous rappelle quand même comme un chapon
une pintade il y a des dates qui sont
très courtes donc ça veut dire en plus
comme le 25 est un jour férier les
magasins sont fermés il ne le vendra pas
le 25 donc sil est à date le 25 il vous
le BR en fait moi le 25 je m'ennuie
grave à chaque fois que j'ai rien à
faire fa ouvrir les cadeaux non ben non
par c'est pas de cadeau donc le 25 à
chaque fois je m'ennuie grave on voir la
télé je te jure je te jure c'est bien
pour ça qu'il y a des film de Noël à la
télé il y aura probablement le Père Noël
est une hordure ouais merci je profite
je profite de ton blouson pour savoir le
poisson papillote c'est une bonne
alternatif pour savoir mais c'est pour
savoir oui est-ce que vous avez des
questions
mamie est-ce qu'il va y avoir des
réductions sur le
Cadon mais je vous entends vous parler
d'or mais si on n'est pas avec vous
faire les courses comment on se
débrouille dans cette jungle en fait ça
dans cette
[Musique]
jungle c'est
[Rires]
la mais frère arrête un peu mais elle
est chez les Mousquetaires cro qu'il y a
des vra
mousquetaires je suisme consommat ésolé
je suis vraiment
désolé oui non mais il faut déjà il faut
déjà accepter l'idée de passer un peu
plus de temps à faire nos courses que ce
que nous faisons c'estàd que on a cette
obsession voilà d'aller viteou c'est
quand même pas un petit sujet ce qu'on
mange voilà et donc il faut regarder les
ingrédients il faut regarder les prix il
faut moi je dis toujours ne faites pas
vos courses avec une liste parce que
quand vous faites avec une liste vous
vous obligez à acheter ce que vous avez
prévu si vous avez par exemple vu euh du
saumon fumé alors que vous aviez prévu
de mettre des huîtres si les huîtreses
sont cher et le saumon fumé pas cher
vous changez la vie